he's well known for his foundation
public resource org he's got a long
history in sort of the deep innards of
the internet did a lot of early work
with multicast including the Internet's
first radio station he's the guy in no
small part responsible for the fact that
the Edgar database of SEC filings is
available online he came to the
attention of many with his 2009 election
campaign for a non elected office he
campaigned for the role of being the
public printer to the United States this
is a role that Ben Franklin my hero
helped bring her out and Carl's campaign
was very specifically looking at
questions of making existing government
documents available online and
downloadable machine readable form
leading to the campaign slogan yes we
scan the job I think this was a terrible
disservice but he did win the 2009 AFF
Pioneer Award for his dedication to
protecting the public domain he's gonna
talk today about another wonderfully
named campaign yo your honor
which I'm looking forward to hearing
more about I know at least that it
focuses at least in part on pacer which
is a system that activists notably Carl
have been calling attention to since
2008 as this is a system that provides
access to critical government documents
court filings etc at the low low price
of ten cents per page thus guaranteeing
that full access to the judicial system
is available for those who have the deep
pockets to pay for it and Carl has
worked with other civic heroes like
Aaron Swartz who have been involved with
downloading large sets of documents from
pacer to study and understand the
problem that they are dealing with Carl
is an amazingly effective and creative
advocate he's someone who is deeply
deeply dedicated
to the notion of civic information and
knowledge has incredible wealth so sort
of understanding around copyright law
and access to information and as always
one of the most creative people thinking
about how to use civic activism to make
a deep change within the US government
so we're thrilled to have him here can't
wait to hear what you have to say
welcome well thank you I really
appreciate being here I was at Harvard
Law School yesterday it's a very
different environment I actually worked
at the Media Lab in 97 after I finished
running the internet world's fair and I
needed a place to land for a while and
Nick Negroponte was kind enough to let
me camp out here and write a book this
was when the Media Lab was one tiny
little building um they had dreams of
building something much bigger and this
is like so amazing it really is a big
difference so um I started my new
nonprofit in 2007 public.resource.org
and the goal was to make all the laws of
America available the idea was that the
primary legal materials what I call the
raw materials of our democracy should be
available not on a pay-per-view basis
not just West and Lexus and a couple big
firms but available for citizens to use
who might not have a credit card and a
subscription and you know a law firm
affiliation but also for researchers to
be able to bring in all the materials
for state statutes for example
reconfigure them into XML data begin
comparing the laws in different
countries analyze in different states
analyzing how those laws work how they
differ making the laws available to the
people because in the United States the
people own the law that's very different
than in other countries in England the
Queen owns the law its crown copyright
but in the United States the people own
the law and because of that the law has
no copyright in the United States so I
began by doing what I thought was the
right thing I did a whole bunch of
workshops around the concept of log of
the and I went to Stanford and Harvard
and the US Congress I went to the Center
for American Progress and we had John
Podesta
Larry tribe and we came up with these
principles of how the law should be
available and it was nice and it was fun
but we didn't actually get anything done
right it didn't change the way the laws
are available in the United States as
part of that though I began kind of
working on some real stuff so we did two
things that was was fairly significant
in 2007 2008 I began posting all the
building codes for the country because
these are the law these are not advisory
codes right these are incorporated into
law in all our states things like the
National Electrical Code and I begin
posting those and nothing happened
nobody sent me takedown notices these
are copyrighted documents these are
created by 501 C 3 nonprofits like the
National Fire Protection Association
American National Standards Institute
the Association American Society for
testing and materials they keep
copyright on these documents but they
want them to be the law they lobby
aggressively for them to be the law and
so I did that for a few years and
nothing much happened I began posting
all the safety standards that are
required by law at the federal level on
the Code of Federal Regulations and then
the [ __ ] kinda hit the fan on that one
we got sued in two district court cases
by six plaintiffs and we're currently in
court it's an intense legal battle
National Fire Protection Association
says they should be the only place that
is allowed to post a National Electrical
Code because if they don't keep the
revenue from the sale of the National
Electrical Code they will be unable to
continue making high-quality codes and
babies will die I have actually heard
that argument and my argument is well
you know I know you need the money it's
a good code but it's the law and in the
law the law in the United States the law
has no copyright and so we've been
posting them and we're fighting very
hard I'm defended by EF F and and two
other law firms like I said there are
six plaintiffs in two district court
cases so this is not an experience you
want to go through among other things I
took every email message from 2007
that I sent to anybody my wife you named
and handed him to my lawyers and the
lawyers went through and did searches
and disclosed anything that was
potentially relevant to the plaintiffs
and so when you're going through a
process like that you learn a lot about
federal litigation the other thing we
did is we began looking at the Pacer
system so pacer is the workings of our
federal courts it's not just the
opinions
it's the dockets it's the motions it's
the briefs
it's the orders it's the arguments that
the lawyers make before the judge
actually rules and the way the Pacer
system works is you pay $0.10 per page
in order to access these you have to
have a valid credit card and if you're a
researcher if you want to download
everything you pay 10 cents a page it'll
cost you a lot of money there's close to
a billion documents in the Pacer system
all over the country and pacer is
expanding its not just a district courts
it's the court of appeals at this point
too now in 2008 I began an enterprise to
say gee let's make pacer more broadly
available hey everybody
download pacer documents upload them to
my site recycle the public domain and I
thought that was just a vehicle for
frequently asked questions learn more
about pacer raise some awareness and I
got a call from a guy named Steve
Schultz he said you know Aaron and I are
working together and we want to do
something I called this download pacer
things the thumb drive Corps the idea
was that there was a free access
mechanism across the country in 20
libraries in order to determine whether
or not maybe the public might have some
interest in pacer because right now you
go to the courts and they say how come
on
nobody needs pacer except for a few
lawyers and so I thought a few people
might download a couple documents it was
a symbolic gesture well Aaron Schwartz
came in and he took the crawler that
Steve Schultz wrote and he won
and he said you know I've got some data
can I upload them to your system I said
well okay it's Aaron will give them an
account and I had a call from my sis and
about a month later he goes you know
we're up to like 700 gigabytes of data
I said well Aaron's a smart boy and I
got a call saying well it turns out all
public access to pacer has been
terminated and they say when they've
called the FBI because they've been
hacked now they weren't hacked right
there was no appropriate use policy
saying only download one document from
the library it didn't say don't download
20 million documents and I'll admit that
was a bit of a surprise to them but it
wasn't illegal they called the FBI FBI
one away and said there's no case here
there's nothing that happened I knew
that there were gonna be privacy issues
in pacer because I had previously put
the court of appeals online and I
thought all whole bunch of social
security numbers in Court of Appeals
opinions and I knew that pacer would
have a similar issue so I did a
comprehensive audit of those twenty
million pages sent in the audit to the
Judicial Conference of the United States
sent it to 32 chief judges of district
courts they ignored me sent him again
and then ended up sending these notices
to chief judges have said third and
final notice in big red letters on the
top and you really got to stop and think
carefully before you do that some judges
wrote back to me and said you know
you're right
there are socials they removed the
documents and I thought that was really
good I thought that was a good thing and
so I stopped working on pacer for a
while that was a pretty strenuous thing
it involved New York Times articles and
you know the Senate sent a letter to the
courts and said what's with all this
privacy problems and the the Judicial
Conference wrote back to the Senate said
all we're aware of this issue now thank
you you know for this audit I got a nice
letter from the chair of the Committee
on rules of the Judicial Conference and
so I kind of left the problem and then
the summer I decided it was time to go
back in and look at it again and the
reason was the courts announced the
administrative office of the courts
announced that they were deleting from
pacer all historical documents for five
courts and all the law librarians in
country like you
what's your deleting the data I mean we
have a shortage of disk space here they
were upgrading pacer to the
next-generation version of pacer but you
know I thought that was really dumb and
so I organized a bunch of letters I went
and called members of Congress there
ended up being six congressmen riding to
the courts there was three senators
wrote to the court saying what are you
doing senator leahy went storming into
the Judicial Conference meeting that was
the topic because he's allowed as chair
of the Senate Judiciary Committee to
address the Judicial Conference and at
the end of the day we all got fooled it
turns out they didn't have any documents
that were historical they had a docket
sheet they had a list of the cases that
had been tried but they didn't have the
briefs and emotions in the orders they
weren't deleting anything and they could
have easily taken this one-page file and
migrated it to the new system but we
were all fooled I should have figured it
out because I knew that they hadn't been
on pacer in the early days but I didn't
senator leahy staff didn't members of
the House Judiciary Committee called the
administrative office up and said what
the hell are you doing on the a/o was
like well it's technically too hard to
do this a single page and so I started
working on a memo on pacer asking myself
what can we do to raise awareness of
this this brain dead system has anybody
actually used pacer have you looked at
it it's all my god I mean this is you
know they set this system up in 1994 and
it looks like it
worst UI you've ever seen no search
capability whatsoever all sorts of other
problems but every time you go talk to
someone they're like what is your
problem
it's just you know it's not a big deal
so I was working on this memo the Chief
Justice every year does a year-end
report it's typically 8 to 10 page
beautifully written essay used to be
they do it on a typewriter and this year
his year-end report was about pacer I
think it's because he didn't like
Senator Leahy yelling at him over that
whole docket controversy we'll never
know
he actually decided to pick this topic
but his year-end report says look in the
judiciary we have to be a little more
conservative and pacer has a billion
documents and for a modest fee any
American can access this data and then
he went on to say and we're gonna put
all the Supreme Court stuff online which
is great that's wonderful all the briefs
everything but we're not gonna use pacer
system and so this rousing defense of
Pacers so I said okay fine the memo I
was working on I turned it into a
response to the Chief Justice which is
not something you're supposed to do they
don't like that happening and in fact my
friends at the Supreme Court don't
return my calls right now because I may
have you just don't do something like
this but my theory is that if people
knew more about the Pacer system they
might do something about it so I have
come up with seven different ways we can
maybe do something so number one let the
judges know you care about pacer because
when I go see a chief judge and I've met
with several of these I actually
addressed a Ninth Circuit in her
business meeting Judge Kozinski asked me
to come in their initial reaction is oh
really
you care about this why and so letting
judges know that this is an issue you
know judges don't get a lot of fan mail
they don't get a lot of lobbying and so
my theory is that if the judge gets 50
postcard saying Your Honor I'm a law
student I'm an engineering student I
followed you know your wonderful opinion
and the great muffin case whatever I
live in Cambridge or the Boston judge if
they get 50 cards maybe they'll say hey
let's look into pacer maybe something's
going on so that's kind of an unusual
technique and what I've done is I've
printed out a whole bunch of postcards
that have pictures of judges Louis
Brandeis I have here mailing labels for
the Honorable patty B saris who is a
chief judge of the Massachusetts
District and we have custom stamps that
have pacer on them
we have pictures of telegraph operators
and the word pacer pictures of clerks
with big books and it says pacer and so
these are not souvenirs but if you want
to write a postcard make sure you only
write on the left hand side because I
need to put a stamp and an address on
the right I'm going around the country
collecting these and on May Day which is
also law day we're gonna open up a pacer
polling place at the Internet Archive
come in and vote for justice vote early
vote often we're gonna have a pacer
polling place in Chicago there's
probably gonna be one in Washington and
my hope is if we collect enough of these
postcards and they go to various judges
maybe the next time the Judicial
Conference gets together they'll start
talking to each other and saying yeah
I've got a bunch of these things oh my
god I had no idea people cared so you
guys are welcome to pass these around
again these are not souvenirs if you
don't want to write a postcard you don't
have to but if you do want to write one
on bring them up at the end and I'll put
a stamp on them I'll put a address label
on them I'll bring them home I'll scan
them all and put them up on Flickr so
that we all see what's going on and then
we'll put them in the mail and send them
to the judges so we can pass these
things around I have more so that's way
number one hearts and minds may not work
I tried that once with the Smithsonian
when they were issuing copyright you
know notices on everything they were
doing we got 300 people to fill out
postcards and they went to members of
Congress and Smithsonian and they
totally ignored us it didn't do anything
so that's the Arts and Letters campaign
let me talk about six a little more more
substantive things one can do about
pacer so the obvious thing is sue the
courts say you're denying me access to
the rights of our judiciary and a
fundamental premise of our judiciary all
the way back to Magna Carta is that we
conduct our hearings of our courts in
public and today that means on the
internet it has to be available to the
public it's the fundamental check on our
system of justice it's the way we know
our courts are fair now
here's the problem it's really hard to
sue the courts for a couple reasons
number one Congress said they should
charge for pacer now they didn't say
they should charge everybody right they
didn't say that they couldn't make it
available for non-commercial use for
free but they did say charge and if you
go to the courts they say well Congress
told us to charge the other problem is
there is no place in the Constitution
that guarantees you a free lunch it is
hard to go in and say my constitutional
rights are being violated I think they
are I think when you charge for access
to pacer the principle of equal
protection has been violated this is a
poll tax on access to justice I think
it's a due process problem I think
there's all sorts of constitutional
issues but it's really hard to bring an
information technology issue up to a
constitutional level and we've tried to
look for ways to sue the courts whether
there's been clinics at different
universities looking into this I've
talked about this with many many lawyers
it's possible but it's hard it's a
stretch so cars and ladders sue the
courts there's a much easier way
Congress Congress said to charge
Congress can also say don't charge it's
really that simple and I've got a simple
magic bullet so right now there's two
ways that the courts bring in external
money they get money from Congress too
but they charge filing fees as well as
pacer fees so if you do federal
litigation you're some big corporate
entity suing over trademark violations
you pay 400 dollars to file your initial
complaint in the federal courts that is
a much bigger revenue stream than the
pacer so they could up the filing fees
just a little bit and get rid of the
pacer fees and that's such an easy thing
to do a member of Congress has actually
put a writer in the appropriations bill
this year that says the administrative
office should drop the pacer fees
increase the filing fees or give us a
report as to what their different
business models are and how they're
examining the issues so we don't think
the courts are actually going to do
anything but maybe they'll have to issue
a report
maybe there'll be hearings it turns out
that Darryl ice is now chairman of the
subcommittee that has oversight of the
operation of the federal courts this is
not something he likes to see 10 cents
per page he's not a lawyer he likes to
break heads and so my hope is that maybe
there's gonna be hearings there's other
people on that committee like
congresswoman Lofgren writes this is
this is a knowledge astre publican
there's a real strong liberal contingent
that use this as a problem so maybe
there'll be hearings maybe not but you
hope for more things and then I'll stop
talking so it turns out pacer has
billing errors their system doesn't work
there are two kinds of things you can do
on pacer you can download a PDF file
which is ten cents per page or three
dollar maximum or you can get what's
called unpatch innate 'add dockets or
search results and those are based on
the number of bytes all right because
it's an HTML file it's supposed to be
ten cents per 4,000 bytes and I'm the
kind of guy when I download my docket I
actually count the number of bytes in
there and I looked at it and I said wait
a minute they're overcharging me so they
charge me 60 cents for like a seven
thousand byte document and so I sent in
a request of the pacer service center
and I asked for my 40 cents back I got a
letter back from them saying we have
received your request we cannot
determine any refunds until after the
billing cycle has completed at which
point we will resolve your request and
I'm reading this going I don't know if
that means I'm gonna get my 40 cents or
not get my 40 cents and then they gave
me advice as to how I could minimize my
bills by you know clicking all sorts of
weird things before doing my search it's
not like this is nuts
and so I proposed I did a formal audit I
actually looked at how far back this
billing error problem goes sent a letter
to the division director of the
administrative office of the United
States courts who has oversight over
pacer and said look you're overcharging
millions of dollars here because
every single docket you're overcharging
it's a most common operation and then I
quoted a court case that is used in
contract 101 if you're in law school I'm
not a lawyer I dropped out after one
year but I did take contracts and
there's a fundamental principle that if
you advertise a price in a supermarket
you have to charge that price right you
can't charge someone more and if
somebody you do charge someone more they
can sue you and get the money back and
that's what I told the courts is that
they have to disgorge this million
dollars or two million dollars or
whatever it is that they've overcharged
systematically for the last several
years and I'm expecting to get mush back
for an answer on that one but I don't
know I've got a meeting next week with
this division director if he doesn't
cancel it and I'm hoping maybe members
of Congress will ask them to shed a
little more light on their finances and
maybe address the billing error problem
remember I said in 2008 I did this
comprehensive audit of privacy problems
so as I was preparing my billing errors
memo on this I I was looking for
public.resource.org on the US courts
website and I discovered I had sent a 24
page memorandum to judge Rosenthal in
2008 that he included a list of every
docket number that I had found
preliminary this is my initial audit
that I had found privacy issues the
document that had the privacy issues and
the social security numbers that I had
found and sure enough an unredacted
version of that audit was on the US
courts gov website actually they posted
it twice one in the civil area in one in
the appellate area unredacted one-stop
shopping for identity theft and I
thought to myself hmm and so I knew I'd
gotten letters back from several chief
judges but several hadn't answered me so
I pulled up to Northern District of
Illinois I took the first document on my
list went to pacer sure enough that
document was still live they hadn't
removed it it was a five page listing of
name home address social security number
of financial information they just
simply had ignored it now what pissed me
off about that is
the United States Senate had sent a
letter to the Judicial Conference saying
what about this privacy issue in 2009
and the courts had written back saying
oh we take this really seriously we're
on top of it we're changing our rules
they did all this analysis of my audit
trying to show that I was wrong they had
a bunch of court functionaries right a
big fancy memorandum but they didn't
remove the documents so I sent a letter
to judge Rosenthal I didn't say that she
had misled the United States Senate's
but it sure looks like they perhaps the
bureaucracy had failed her and I
actually talked to judge Rosenthal and I
apologized I said look I'm really sorry
because she was really nice to me I mean
she met me in chambers in 2010 sent me a
nice letter back thanking me for my work
and I know she didn't post this document
on US courts guv but it was a letter to
her and I had her name on it and so
that's a big issue and I'm hoping that
maybe some members of Congress maybe
some members of the Senate's might want
to get a further explanation with the
administrative office as to how the
current situation relates to the
assurances that they gave the Senate in
2009 two more things my initial idea in
this memo was in pacer if you use
fifteen dollars or less per quarter they
don't bill you it's their one kind of
free access thing now you have to have a
credit card and you have to register but
the idea was that maybe everybody around
the country would use their 15 bucks
every quarter and they would use the
recap plugin which takes this document
and puts it up on the Internet Archive
and we've got over a million cases on
the Internet Archive it's a small
percentage of pacer but it's a
reasonable subset and my idea was that
maybe law students all over the country
would band together and there'd be a
little competition to see which law
school downloaded the most documents
right and so there's going to be an
extension of the recap plugin where you
can fill in a group name
filled Harvard Law School or Boston or
whatever any idea was that the winning
law school would get the Swartz cup and
we have a beautiful marble column this
is Swartz law day and the idea is we
would do this on May 1 now May 1 you may
know it as May Day but during the 1950s
McCarthy and folks like that decided
they didn't like all this communist
stuff and so they decided May 1 would be
law day and the American Bar Association
embraced law day with a vengeance and
this May 1 they are doing the 800th
anniversary of Magna Carta there will be
speeches are gonna go to Runnymede
they're gonna cut a ribbon and I figured
this was an appropriate alternative to
law day now I haven't had a whole bunch
of law students calling me up saying
we're gonna do this this will be great
and so I I'm not sure we're gonna have a
huge number of downloads on law day but
yeah you know I'm gonna keep trying and
maybe we'll get there and we're gonna
keep doing this for several years by the
way it takes ten years usually to get
one of these big databases online took
10 years to get the US Patent database
online it's probably gonna take 10 years
to do pacer I start in 2008 we may not
even succeed in 2018 but we're gonna
keep doing the download you're 15 bucks
per quarter and see if maybe that'll
turn into something and then finally and
this is I think our best shot
so last week I filed a application for a
fee exemption which you're allowed to do
if you're prisoner you can petition a
judge and say I want free pacer and the
way that works is you only get free
patient on a special account you're not
allowed to redistribute the data you
have to limit your you know it's a
carefully constrained thing so
occasionally nonprofits get fee
exemptions so our fee exemption request
went straight to the Ninth Circuit and
said we want an entire district an
entire district court we'd actually like
for district courts and the Ninth
Circuit so we applied for a fee
exemption for five courts and what we
said is we will download every document
for that district and we
audited for privacy violations footnote
you've got a problem right you get we
found a problem last week still this is
a pressing issue and we will report back
to the court as to whether your privacy
rules are being observed or not we will
notify each of the litigants when we
find a Social Security number and notify
them of the problem so we're performing
a service for the courts we'll do it one
district well do four districts we'll do
the circuit you choose and our argument
is that the courts kind of need to have
this done but we did something else in
this one we said look not only are we
gonna redact these documents we want to
post them all on the internet archive
phone and we included affidavits from
leading legal researchers say oh my god
if you had an entire court available we
could do some amazing things affidavits
from Brewster Kahle sang will host the
data from Brian Carver at the free law
project we have a public library
librarian we have the Lewis and Clark
library and they've all submitted
affidavits in our argument is the courts
have the authority to grant our request
and they owe it to themselves to conduct
at least one experiment to see whether
there's a better way right now every
single District Court 10 cents a page
same mechanism the Ninth Circuit is a
huge place our argument to the court is
they should at least try one district
and see if better public access and
analysis of privacy and all this
empirical research that people could do
see if maybe that's a better way to do
things and I have no idea of Chief Judge
Thomas is gonna be able to grant our
request at the very least we think the
administrative office of the United
States courts will be asked to submit a
report to the Ninth Circuit explaining
why I'm stupid and maybe we'll get an
in-depth explanation of why they think
this is a bad idea so if nothing else
this is gonna force them to the table so
that's the seven mechanisms I've come up
with on a piece of strategy some are
going to work some are not right going
to Congress is ultimately maybe the best
way to do it
auditing for billing errors and privacy
viola
is something substantial and real that
they really have to fix maybe that's
gonna force them to look at it maybe
just letting the judges know because
when I see a judge and I say we got a
pacer problem they're like oh really I
didn't know that because they don't use
pacer right they have clerks or one may
use pacer it's just occasional but
usually they just have a pile of paper
on their desk and that's what they read
and so letting them and members of
Congress and others know that we
actually care about this thing I think
may may do something and maybe our
system of justice will work on our fee
exemption request will be granted you
never know
excellent thank you absolutely about
pacer or about any other start the
conversation so what is pacer what is
technically what is pacer so pacer is a
weird distributed system it is built by
some contractors at the pacer service
center in Texas each court has their own
implementation of pacer so what that
means is you cannot search across a
whole bunch of courts there is something
called a federal case locator which is
sort of gets you a little bit of that it
used to be a whole bunch of Perl code
and you can tell it's Perl code it's
very easy to figure that out
they have been upgrading to next-gen
pacer which as best as I can tell is
Java based
and has features like longer usernames
today now that when I sent a letter in
to the administrator of the
administrative office and said you know
here's my pamphlet and I want to talk to
you about pay so I got a letter back for
mr. Lonnie and mr. Lonnie said I read
your pamphlet that you sent to the
director and every single suggestion
that you had in there is something we're
working on for a future release so it's
really it's it's a single system per
district or per appellate because now
the Court of Appeals all have to be on
this system and whether it's a single
server farm or I don't know because they
won't tell us they also won't tell us
like how many dockets that they do every
year or how many of their users they
claim that 80% of pacer users are not
charged under this $15 per quarter thing
I don't believe that number I think what
they've done is taken every person who's
ever registered for pacer and even if
they're not using it today they count it
as oh you got free access I think that's
what's going on I think most of their
attorneys get free pacer for their own
cases I think that's a lot of their
usage is attorneys downloading their own
filings I know West Alexis bloomberg do
a lot of pacer access but again we don't
know the answer to that and so I wish I
could give you more details but that's
actually one of my frustrations is you
know I've been doing this since 2008 I
have spoken once briefly with a member
of the administrative office I was asked
to speak at a panel on pacer and the
administrative office let it be known
that if I was there they wouldn't be
there and so I was disinvited so pretty
free law and I can understand the value
of having those available for free
building code context why would that
mean I obviously know the code it has
been adopted so the question I have is
in the pacer context what aren't them
what are the beneficial uses to the
public like so much of it is kind of in
the weeds for lawyers in a particular
case so there's two two important
answers the question is one of the
beneficial uses of pacer as opposed to
the law must be available that's pretty
clear the opinions of the court must be
available everybody agrees on that
although not all the opinions are
available so there's two answers to this
one is right now the courts have not
decided what should be public and what
should not so for example bankruptcy
proceedings have an incredible amount of
personal information I am not convinced
that data necessarily needs to be on
Google on there are some compelling
reasons that some bankruptcy proceedings
should be but my argument there that is
if it's available on pace or for 10
cents a page and on West and on Lexus it
should also be available to others so
the question is who are the others that
don't have access to pacer today if you
are a journalist and you're doing
significant work on the federal courts
you got to go see your editor because
you're gonna rack up some real bills
right you can't go look at a hundred
different court cases in a district to
understand whether people of different
ethnic Heritage's are being stopped more
often for crimes or violations right you
can't do that empirical research today
on pacer if you are an academic
researcher who wants to look at again
civil rights litigation across different
districts does the south in for civil
rights differently than Missouri what
about patent litigation is that being
done in a uniform basis what are
important cases there's a whole raft of
empirical research that we're beginning
to see
there's young law professors at Michigan
State University there's a guy named
Matthew sag at Loyola in Chicago Dazza
Greenwood here at MIT Media Lab is
beginning to do that kind of stuff and
and that research is precluded because
there's just no way you can download
everything from a district and do that
empirical research you can't do my
social security thing right that's my
one trick is I'll download everything
and run run reg axon it's just dummy
it's not very hard to do you run OCR and
then you take the text files and you
know you do grep but nobody else does
that and it's one of the things I know
how to do I've done it with the IRS I
can do with the courts I can't do that
at ten cents a page well yes I am but
the professors are the ones that do the
big data analysis and there's some very
compelling big data analysis that has
come out of analysis of Supreme Court
opinions they do citation analysis
they're able to determine which cases
really are important because they're
cited so for example there was an
analysis of Marbury vs. Madison Wright
seminal case we know it is one of the
landmark cases well it turns out Marbury
vs. Madison was not an important case
until the Interstate Commerce Commission
began to do its work and an industry
started to happen and so you can
actually see by citation analysis that
this case became much more important in
the late 1800s now that's sort of
intuitive we could kind of figure that
out but at a lower level a court of
appeals court it would be interesting to
analyze what are in fact the important
cases that this particular judge has
authored and so there is a lot of big
data analysis that I think is
significant there's a lot of muckraking
and journalism work that I think is very
significant and there's a lot of
citizens that I think want to follow
cases and some of them they can do on
recap but a lot of times they can often
I've gotten this with every database
I've done line two SEC patent you know
you go into the Securities and Exchange
Commission saying edgar ought to be
online and the answer is you know people
don't really care about this it's just a
few financial if fat cats why should we
subsidize their use right if you make
Pacer free it's only the lawyers are
gonna
on it and they're gonna have no you know
why shouldn't they just pay their way
they got lots of money and the answer to
that is you're precluding a much broader
audience that actually really does have
an interest in the proceedings of the
courts maybe not everything but there's
enough cases out there that you know
I'll give you a simple example I know a
lady who had a crooked landlord it turns
out he was involved in all sorts of
court cases she went on to pacer to
research because she was renting from
this person and because of I believe
billing error she racked up a thirty
thousand dollar bill I think it's
because she was searching a lot into
this whole on paginate at ten cents per
page thing the courts called out a
collection agency after her put a black
mark on her credit record she's a young
single mom she happens to work for a
judge he couldn't step in because you
know he can't really intervene and as
far as I could tell it was a totally
bogus claim but she wanted to research
her landlord and see what was going on
and that was hard to do Carl I got a
tactical question in from Charlie Tatar
who's a former doctoral student here at
the the Media Lab and he points out that
it's really hard to get people involved
with campaigns focused on the US
government and and trying to figure out
how you get people into those campaigns
instead of an art form in and of itself
so we have folks like John Oliver you
know making these very blunt statements
about the NSA has your dick pics and
Charlie observes that you know yo you're
honored org he's pretty dense and pretty
technical you're writing it it you you
know in the form of essentially a legal
filing what what's the what's the choice
behind that what why go after it in in
this way are you trying to build a broad
movement of this are you trying to make
a few visible provocations what's what's
the theory of change on this and
and how has how you've launched this
plate into this I think it's all of
those so the first thing I wanted to do
is write a memo somewhat for myself as
to what are the different ways we can
solve the Pacer problem and I want it to
have enough facts that someone that took
the time to read this could turn around
and and you know maybe explain it in
simpler language and as you can see I'm
going around the country trying to
explain it in simpler language this may
be too much but it seemed to me that at
some point you really got to dig into
the facts and begin to address the
issues of is there a constitutional
right to pacer what about the exemptions
how do they work what about the billing
and it just seemed necessary to put it
together and that's got to be dense
building a broad movement around this
stuff I have failed miserably every time
I've tried to do this ok I did law at
fifteen workshops hundreds of people
principals but it didn't change anything
I've been going after the Smithsonian
for years because they assert copyright
over over their materials I say you got
to have a license to use public domain
materials and I think that's nuts but I
got three hundred people to do postcards
but that's because I basically you know
grabbed three hundred people by the
elbow and forced in the write-up so that
that was getting a broad movement I
don't know you know I don't know what it
takes to do that
Aaron seemed to have figured that out on
SOPA you know was able to mobilize along
with a bunch of other people a huge
outpouring over a very important and
somewhat obscure issue one that normally
the MPAA would have just been able to
get SOPA done and people were able to
get a lot of people standing up but I've
never figured out that magic ticket and
so at the end of the day this is a
series of tactical efforts that I'm
hoping one or more of them will actually
do something and so there's a fee
exemption there's billing errors there's
privacy problems as cards and letters
are any of them going to work I don't
know I don't know but I think you just
got to keep trying and I think it takes
sustained effort like I said it takes
you know you got to just keep on doing
this and eventually if you think you're
right you know maybe what I find is when
you meet a policymaker and you get those
five minutes with
usually at the end of those five minutes
are beginning to shake their head they
have some doubts but they understand
that this isn't totally nuts maybe it's
something we need to look into and so
that's really the hope is you get enough
people saying okay I'll get some staff
looking into this maybe there is
somewhat of a pacer problem and like I
said most you know the administrative
office thinks we're nuts
they think we're making a lot of noise
over nothing but to me it's a
fundamental principle because you know
if pacer is behind a paywall what is to
prevent your state regulations for being
behind a paywall or your building code
behind a paywall and to me our federal
judiciary is is like one of the most
important sources of what is truly
public domain raw materials that we need
to be able to access and I think if you
permit that data to be buried and behind
then all of a sudden you get the state
of Georgia in the state of Mississippi
in the state of Idaho sending me
takedown letters which they have for
posting their official state codes
online and they haven't sued because I
don't think they have any legal ground
to stand on but you know the state of
Delaware the the the corporation code of
Delaware has a provision in it that says
if you copy the corporate code of
Delaware without permission from the
Secretary of State you can go to jail
for three months clearly
unconstitutional but it's on the books
and I think that's really the core
principle is raising awareness that
again edicts of government the primary
legal materials of the United States
need to be available I'll grant you that
pacer is a lot of secondary materials as
well as primary but you can't have the
primary materials without the underlying
briefs right it's like the Supreme Court
you got Marbury vs. Madison online but
you don't have the briefs that the
lawyers argued and I think that's a
vital part it's like the legislature
right we have our laws online but we
also need the congressional hearings
that led to the laws because when you go
to court you're gonna argue not about
the law but also about legislative
intent when you appeal a court decision
you're going to be looking not just at
the courts opinion
but at the briefs and the arguments that
the lawyers made and so I think any
entity that emits edicts of government
things that we have to like live by also
has to admit to supporting materials
that are underneath those and that's
kind of the big picture well you know I
I sent out notes to all sorts of places
saying hey I'm doing piece of this month
and all sorts of law schools not one of
them said all gee come on and come on in
and talk because they got Bloomberg or
something else I am finding all the
legal hacker communities and journalists
are intensely interested in this issue
so that's who I'm trying to reach out
you are folks that are not already you
know having access to the system I was a
little disappointed though because I
thought more law students would view
this as a fundamental issue the law
librarians get it right they're totally
behind this campaign the professors are
kind of like a you know I do justice I
do the Constitution I don't this is a
legal research thing and so getting them
to pay attention is kind of hard so
again I don't know what the answer is to
getting people to stand up and say
something but I'm trying different ways
and seeing if any of them work
tesseract something like that I guess my
question is you know with say SEC FDR
like a lot of this data you can download
I think
CSU is very kind of structured format so
if you see this kind of first campaign
to
all these PS you see that as a stepping
stone to eventually like lawyers like so
of question is what is the technical
path here so FCC was actual real data
when I when I did it and now it's XBRL
which is nice you know XML formatted
information really well done pacer
everybody pretty much efj Isles with the
one exception
my ninth circuit brief that I sent in it
turns out if you want to e-file
something to the ninth circuit you can
only do that if you're appealing an
existing decision and since we're not
appealing a decision we had to print it
out bring it to the clerk's office which
then scanned it and put it online now
the folks that do e file many of those
actually are born digital documents some
lawyers print them out scan them and
then e-file them and so the long term
path is if we begin getting broader
access and doing research maybe we can
get better standards on docket formats
maybe so today if you file in some
courts you cannot have an active
hyperlink so even if you got a URL there
it can't have a link under and so the
last thing that a lot of law firms do is
you know they like my briefs all have
you know a ton of URLs in them this may
be viewed at the following URL they have
to remove the underlying hyperlink maybe
we could convince the administrative
office that hyperlinks are okay I
understand why they don't want them in
there because they're afraid that
they'll resolve to something weird a
virus will be introduced you know
whatever but yeah that's the hope is
that if all of a sudden there is broader
access to the data more people using the
data you know every state has a
different docket format and it makes it
really hard to analyze state court
decisions so maybe maybe there's room
for a standard there on hopefully some
simple XML format although who knows
when when they all get together you end
up with some you know million options
DTD and schema but you know you can
always hope they do it right but yeah
that's the hope is that more people use
this stuff right now it's West Lexus and
Bloomberg are the big users of the data
and they don't complain because one of
the things they do is they
add value to this data and they try to
compete right and so it's not like a
researcher being able to knock on a door
and say you know we could do this much
better I actually think if we had a
broader base of user as West and Lexus
and the others would also stand up and
begin asking for better better
formatting of the underlying information
because it's a pain in the neck for them
every one of them has to do the same
thing that the they do so help me sort
of zoom out and get the big picture
you've been involved with an enormous
number of fights about the public domain
about access to government information
you know pacer is one that I think many
of us heard of because Aaron was very
good at sort of attracting attention to
it and obviously you know as people have
gone back and learned about Aaron's
legacy it's something that people have
learned about as well you just refer to
it and in some ways it's saying this
month I'm doing pacer help me understand
sort of the larger arm of your work at
this point what are the interrelated
issues that you're working on how do
they work together towards seeing the
change that that you want to see within
the US this is all about access to
knowledge right this is about letting
anybody who has a computer on the
Internet and today that means anybody
anywhere in the world being able to
bootstrap themselves up and educate
themselves about something I learned
about the tcp/ip protocols by
downloading all the RFC s and reading
the things and that's how I learned
about the Internet I could have gone to
college and learn but you know what I
didn't do that I did something else in
college but to me it's very important
that we have access to knowledge in in a
broad framework right not not just the
stuff I do but the entire Library of
Congress should be digitized and
available as Aaron Schwartz was looking
at JSTOR right important scientific
journals should be available on a
broader basis to me that's a fundamental
human right that is possible because of
the internet and the area that I focus
in is mostly the
government and the state government and
I do that because there's a hook because
with the federal government works of
government have no copyright right we
have a right to that information and so
it's something that I can go in and say
you know what just give us the data it's
a technical issue the law
similarly works of government is a
federal issue right in the United States
works of the federal government have no
copyright but in the United States the
law has no copyright state municipal
anything that is an edict of government
has no copyright and that is the area
that I specialize in because it's a hook
right it's something I can look at that
and say this is important information to
meet technical standards things like
building codes are not just a law
they're the codification of engineering
knowledge right the National Electrical
Code is the way to safely do electricity
in the United States maybe it's not the
optimal way to do it but it's the way
that everyone has gotten together and
agreed it's an incredible educational
tool for a young person wanting to be an
electrical contractor or wanting to be a
plumber or a factory worker trying to
understand what makes a safe ladder it's
a codification of technical knowledge
and that's some of the most important
laws in our modern world because if you
look at things like Civil Procedure and
Criminal Procedure most people don't
interact with that but every homeowner
has to deal with the fact that their
electrical outlets have to be you know
no more than three feet apart and the
reason for that is you don't want big
long cord stretching across the floor
now here at the Media Lab you probably
have those cords all over the floor but
again it's the kind of thing that that
is education about how to practice our
modern world safely how to safely
transport oil in rail cars how to make
factories safe how to make our
environment safe and again it may not be
optimal knowledge maybe you don't like
the EPA regulations but if you can't
read them and discuss them then we're
never gonna get better laws we're never
gonna get better knowledge of that sort
so to me it's about education but also
about justice and democracy and you know
those kinds of
things because I think that's an
important thing in the United States we
are overly lowered and one of the
reasons is you have to be part of the
guild in order to access the material
and as I've been doing this issue for a
while there are so many people that are
non lawyers that are intensely
interested in the operation of our
system of justice and I think those
people should have the same access as
those that are actually practicing
inside so the ideal outcome for you
is a one in which anything that that
ends up being law or sort of background
material to the law is freely publicly
accessible and the transformation you
hope to see from that is law being more
open to the non-professional either in
terms of activism or in terms of
participation with more open and better
more open better and we're doing this
and so this whole technical safety codes
thing I'm doing not just in the US we're
doing it in Europe and we're doing it in
India and in India there's an incredibly
strong reason that that these public
safety codes have to be available that's
because the Indian Constitution has
fundamental rights they're like our Bill
of Rights and you know fundamental
rights our freedom of speech but there's
another one in there which is the right
to practice your profession
it's a caste thing right in India you
can't say you can't be a plumber because
you were born in this caste and so it's
a fundamental right under the Indian
Constitution the Indian standards are
all about how to do plumbing safely how
to be a safe textile worker how to do
irrigation how to build dams and so we
have a very strong constitutional
argument in India that these technical
standards should be available just like
in the United States if it's the law
it's got to be public so yeah the hope
is that we get this basic principle in
the United States I've been advocating
and edicts of government amendment to
the Copyright Act which follows on
copyright office procedure that says
edicts of government have no copyright
in the United States long run of Supreme
Court opinions have said that the law
has no copyright but getting Congress to
say that would solve some of these
problems we had
in the state of Georgia and with the
National Electrical Code and with
municipalities having copyright over
there there there's there's city
ordinances and suing people for making
copies of them it's a fundamental
problem it's also got an effect that I
think is really important if you look at
legal tools anybody use West or Lexus or
Bloomberg have you used any of those
systems they're awful oh my god the
innovation that we've seen on the
Internet has just not hit the legal
profession and I think one of the
reasons is we've got these walls around
our primary legal materials so when I go
speak to a judge I say one of the things
they're gonna get is justice and
democracy but you're also gonna get
better tools because right now if you're
an internet startup and you want to like
gather all the statutes and court
opinions and stuff it's a 10 to 20
million dollar endeavor to do that it
ought to be just simply just download
the silly things but it is hard to get
those materials and so you're not
getting any clue for internet startups
going after West and Lexus now the only
ones that are doing that are companies
like Bloomberg that are very very deep
pockets and they've reinvented West it's
better than West but you know it's not
not at the level that we kind of expect
from Silicon Valley anybody else could
good
so States Dakota it is is an XML format
that Waldo Joe Keith put together for
the state of Virginia
my friend Seamus Kraft does a lot of
municipal codes and I've actually been
very active in that effort I got about
1500 municipal codes and put them online
and based on that a lot of cities
decided that maybe they wanted to work
with Seamus to like get their code up
and we've had remarkable success at the
city level cities Chicago San Francisco
Baltimore all have open data available
XML format it's really cool for public
domain Washington DC did an amazing job
they actually now have the official
version of the DC code is available with
a CC 0 stamp on it no rights asserted
not not just an unofficial version but
an official version and so yeah change
kind of bubbles up from the bottom we've
had much better luck with the cities
than we had with states and the federal
government much more responsive because
people read their municipal codes right
you do a better municipal code and
you're the city clerk we found this in
Chicago that City Clerk's can get all
sorts of fan mail from Realtors and
insurance people and contractors they're
all gonna go wow this is way better so
huge kind of upside for those folks to
make those laws available I don't know I
don't know I you know how you get that
magic moment where all the sudden change
occurs some of its serendipity some of
it states are bigger they're older
they're less in touch with the people
the people that do the law are low down
in the state government whereas a city
clerk is usually an elected office and
has a certain degree of autonomy so I
wanted to be public printer of the
United States I wouldn't have had
authority to make decisions but you know
when you're a constitutional officer or
your Senate confirm person you can at
least go knocking on the door of someone
else and they'll probably take the
meeting right the administrative office
is avoided meeting me but I know if I
was public printer the United States
they probably would have the least met
me
or twice that but sorry no which does it
turns out is sort of one of the great
open questions in civics at the moment
there is a reasonable amount of
enthusiasm for the idea that there could
be change possible at city levels and
you hear people saying things like you
know mayors are the new presidents like
that those are the races we care about
that's where we actually feel like we're
going to have influence but of course
part of what's going on is that people
then find themselves sort of abandoning
the battles at a state or a national or
international level due in part to sort
of lack of confidence within those
institutions so that question of sort of
how you take momentum that's going on in
a city level and figuring on how to get
it to scale up the stack is actually a
pretty critical question for the field
as a whole I'm giving a speech tomorrow
night at Civic Hall for Code for America
in New York and one of the things I'm
going to talk about there is the Civil
Service Commission in the late 1800s
because our federal bureaucracy was
totally totally broken
for one thing every time a new president
came in the entire staff got fired and
they hired a bunch of new people not
just the post office as a patent office
a whole bed Teddy Roosevelt joined the
Civil Service Commission and they had
statutory authority to go in to the
agencies and totally reboot their
personnel policies and that is what made
the Progressive Era possible right there
wouldn't have been a Food and Drug
Administration there wouldn't have been
a Securities and Exchange Commission
there wouldn't have been a lot of the
antitrust laws effectively done by the
Department of Justice if they hadn't
reformed civil service and to me the
fundamental problem at the state and the
federal level is broken
information technology eighty billion
dollars a year spent on federal IT I
happen to have done a lot of work on the
IRS two billion dollars a year they
spent on on information technology and a
lot of that is on Windows XP platforms
they had to get a special waiver from
Microsoft to continue supporting Windows
XP the exempt organizations database is
processed on a Windows XP box with an
Oracle application on top so to me
that's a fundamental problem at the
federal level that's
why we can't get changed cuz you go see
the archivist of the United States
wonderful guy David Ferriero and you say
you know I don't like the way you're
doing electronic archiving he'll sigh
you know he's got this thousand page
contract with Lockheed Martin it would
be really hard to change that it's just
really hard to go in and say we want to
do things better even if you want to do
things better and to me that's a
fundamental issue it's it's a kind of
bootstrap issue that if we don't solve
that in our federal government we're
gonna continue to have a gridlock
federal bureaucracy because the tools we
give our civil servants many of them are
amazingly talented and dedicated to
public servant public service those
tools suck they're really really bad
Megan Smith right chief technology
officer of the United States used to run
Google X is sitting there on a Dell box
running you know Windows 7 or Windows 8
or whatever but she can't go oh gee I
wanna you know I'm gonna run UNIX or a
Mac or whatever it's just fundamentally
hard to do changes in IT and that means
you can't change the way government
works and to me that's something that
you're not going to do incremental
that's my my big argument with our chief
information officers and OMB and the
folks of very dedicated people that are
trying to solve our procurement problems
but I don't think it's enough right I
think it's something that the president
and members of Congress and others need
to say this is a real problem we need to
solve this because you know you look at
a lot of these billion-dollar systems
that they build and the state of
California three billion dollars to
automate the courts do a little math on
now on and try to figure out if you
could spend three billion dollars to
automate that many courts it's a lot of
money and the system never worked they
had to throw it away the FAA the
next-gen system for the future of air
navigation hasn't worked it's not gonna
work it probably needs to be shot the
Patent Office really good people went
into the Patent Office but they're still
running need a s400 they're missing
source code on key applications I want
to see the commissioner
said you know you gotta have all the
patents online all you got to do is put
in an FTP server and his first reaction
you looks amigos well you've obviously
never worked on government stuff before
I said well you know I actually put the
patent database online three times he
goes well my electrical grid is at 96%
if I plug in one more computer the whole
building goes down and I'm looking at
I'm gonna say well you know we could
shoot some of those as400 s and get you
a few watts of electricity and maybe we
could throw in a few blade servers but
you know that was not the conversation
you have with an Undersecretary of
Commerce so luckily Google went in and
was able to do all the bulk patent data
and make it available for everybody and
and it was a big win but you know that I
started that database in 94 John or want
who is right up the road is the guy that
did the Google patent thing and you know
that was 2009 2010 and even now they're
retrenching they had it online then they
took the thing away from Google and now
they have another contractor and it's
still not available the way it should be
so we probably a ton for one last
question anybody wanna want to throw
great went out there so close this up
they figure that out and that's why I
have a meeting next week with mr. Lonnie
so they understand that's a PR issue
about thirty million dollars a year
partner justice has to pay to access
pacer and I have never seen this memo
but I heard from an assistant US
attorney that occasionally they get a
memo saying we're over-budget please
stop defending the government so
aggressively because we're spending too
much on patience pacer hearings I think
a big pacer hearing and Congress would
would be a good way if they invited the
right people to talk would be a good way
to begin turning this into something
that perhaps the Washington Post or
others right now it's really hard to get
mainstream media to write this up unless
there's some huge scandal or privacy
problem you know we hit the New York
Times with our privacy audit but that's
simply because it was so colorfully done
but there hasn't been a lot of pacer
stuff since then so yeah I mean how do i
it's partly a PR issue and again I just
never know when something hits that big
PR button and people get interested i RS
you know you would have thought 600,000
social security numbers in the exempt
organization database was a huge scandal
particularly given all the Lois Lerner
stuff that was going on we got very
little press on that very little
congressional interest you know so this
is a room full of people who spend a lot
of time thinking about how you build
popular movements are
Thanks if anyone wants to come and
advise Carl and try to figure out how
you build a big movement on this I'm
sure he would welcome the conversation
for everyone who's taken a pacer
postcard I would ask you to please write
your thoughts on pacer bring them back
to Carl so that they can be sent to the
state judiciary and let's have a round
of applause thank you and if you don't
have anything to say about peso just
pass up the blank postcards now you know
you don't have to do the postcards you
can just send a letter to a judge I mean
that works as well but what I'm trying
to do is collect as many of these so if
I have enough I'll put them up on Flickr
and you know not only the judges get
them but other people can see them